we want to end tonight with some great
news don't have a lot of it but this is
great this is Kelly McNally she's one of
our favorite people she works here
whenever you see people on this show and
you wonder who convinced them to come
here it was likely Kelly McNally she's
that nice on Saturday she married her
match rate Ernie he also works at Fox
he is also universally loved here Kelly
and Ray were married at the Church of
the Epiphany in Miami so we loaded up
the TCT van and headed down to cheer
them on is there anything better than
seeing good people marry each other I
can't think of anything it was wonderful
congratulations to Kelly and Ray you are
making the world better in the only way
that matters you want to improve this
world marry someone decent that is true